ce penalty manqué et un tournant dans ce
championnat de d2 de district après cet
échec montigny le bretonneux deuxième du
classement ne gagnera pas ce dimanche 29
mai sur sa pelouse face au leader ou ya
saut et deux équipes se séparent sur un
match nul score final 1 partout très
difficile le match a pris une très bonne
équipe à moutier bretons leur gardien
même défensivement ils sont bons bas
depuis le début de saison sont là on
s'accroche avec eux pour la première la
deuxième place une déception puisque
regard du scénario surtout des occasions
de but avec les deux frappes sur la
barre et le penalty raté on avait moyen
de s'imposer après je trouve qu'on a on
a joué un peu avec le frein à main on a
eu du mal à se lâcher offensivement on a
dû faire mieux et on a laissé toujours
oui dans le match et ils auraient pu
même nous faire mal sur la fin de match
donc voilà c'est une déception
effectivement ce résultat arrange ou qui
reste premier du classement à une
journée de la fin de la saison le club
compte un point de plus que montigny le
bretonneux après 21 journées disputées
et d'oujda énorme saison sont là aussi
les supporters la fin de gros saison le
coach il est là il nous fallait juste un
nul déjà pour la montée c'est parfait on
va valider ça et maintenant on va aller
fêter ça comme il se doit montigny le
bretonneux aura encore une infime chance
de monter ce dimanche 5 juin pour cela
les inimités 1 se déplaceront sur le
terrain de l'équipe 3 de versailles de
son côté où se rendra à quoi n'ya pour
clôturer la saison